ah Jesus penis
calm
if I put one of these day
they don't explode [ __ ] great
give me stuff
give me stop
get you down a comer
they're so [ __ ] annoying
yeah I can't solve these [ __ ] peanuts
are we doing long
I was [ __ ] MLG it was behind here
though
more [ __ ] now
come on
okay let's think think this is a great
much starch and dirt I've met
so annoying
Louie wears bluey
where's bluey there you go you're going
down here you stupid piece of juice
I wish I could get it quiet
and ideas getting [ __ ] tired of this
is this
oh sweet
I got it
okay got it
yeah good just give me a more something
[ __ ] you
ha ha you're not so tough now are you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
come on I don't have time for that
where where Jesus Christ
okay [ __ ] solid just let me finish
[ __ ] you I won't cut it out
shut the [ __ ] up you [ __ ] [ __ ] did
their [ __ ] sweater me
[ __ ] ruin it hey I'm a bad voice
actor Murray River
Bosh
are you know French now you [ __ ]
[ __ ] whoa what the
ah she wants a hug
I want ax although she's so ugly
I can't be she can't be here stop
I can imagine [ __ ] goes down I'm so
funny what am i doing now
ah crap huh
hey dynamo is awesome way
actually not but whatever all right
let's keep it going come on I'm almost
dead now
I can just a minute gotta go drain the
old worm okay see ya
okay let's be more cautious now [ __ ]
shotgun
Jesus penis
a chef whoa balls ah okay let's give
more [ __ ] ouch she can't be penis to
get them a penis
that's fair Mike Mike Mike Mike cut my
sweet sweet double sweet right
one over your [ __ ] how does these
[ __ ] look like he's curious
I think it's really [ __ ] annoying
you kindly
yes
if you can [ __ ] with my mind why doesn't
mean why does it keep summing 1 or 2
it's so stupid
that's [ __ ] POG doesn't happen
we're done but I will you know the same
oh because this is creepy I'm even
sliding okay we store they're all
identical so I guess okay not that
I had a feeling that was the wrong one
okay it must be this one okay then it's
this one it's neither
[Applause]
[Laughter]
because they're not what oh sweet
[Music]
going on here this blood pulsing walls
nothing new no problem
alright let's go ah mattock
though boobs bomb
ah that it couldn't say Matic its I stop
doing that please okay it's fine it's
fine it's fine
[Music]
I
it's [ __ ] worse I voice acting is
worse than that [ __ ]
it's not fussing that's how I got that
she's using you
Oh
oh I thought the prologue was just to
introduce the game or something
come on give me a [ __ ] break when am
I gonna hit this I'm gonna
it's just one left now
come on stop humping my face Jesus
Christ
I will with my good looks hello lady
she'll melt like I hope she saves you
from this butter biscuit and oh this is
not good
oh no nope nope no no no nope nope nope
nope nope nope nope nope nope nope oh no
no no what the [ __ ] is going on oh no no
no no no no I'm not going back to that
[ __ ] house again get up stupid
get up all so now we get to know what
happened
and we got to a mental hospital I was
quick
all the way here
Oh Elsie
haha if I can own them okay let's go for
this one
yeah yeah yeah come on let's get this
quick before they have my face okay
don't hop my face
humph my face don't think
I'm ADA ya mean we mean we we need me
what the [ __ ] am i doing cuz I'm laying
down again uh my stomach oh there is he
wants to make out doesn't he
oh [ __ ]
oh man now he's mine [ __ ]
oh no he's not my there's someone there
don't give me false
whoa what the balls whoa what the balls
what balls balls on the walls he's not
that after I hold it [ __ ] Oh bro bro no
okay let's go with the good looks
hello lady
thank you really what do I do looks like
that I that I told him meant to do that
alright so that was nine per house - I I
wish I hadn't take a break like a mom
between and I wish oh whatever it's a
it's over it was just a mod anyway it's
not like a real game or anything but it
was fun
holy [ __ ] the prologue was probably the
worst one uh it was probably one of the
worst like scarce or whatever but the
main game it was kind of so-so to be
honest yeah it's good it's a it's a
freaking mod it's free so I mean I'm
fine with stuffing stuff you know
I'm guessing there's nothing in behind
the credits so there's like no point on
me really waiting or anything I'm not
sure if I'm gonna start a new you Leslie
or not before the summer because I don't
really have internet where I say I'm
gonna work as a harbor captain yeah at
the restrictions so if anyone is out
sailing I'll probably greet to you in
the harbor but like I said I have no
internet so I'll see what I'll do I
can't say anything for sure yet we
create stuff all right good [ __ ] for
you
but I hope you enjoyed this last half of
me playing a night my house wasn't that
scary that [ __ ] mannequin snow Jesus
Christ at the end all right
I guess I'm gonna sign off okay I always
do why am i keeping my hands busy okay I
guess I'll wait it's just
you know do you know
okay awkward silence come on finish it
is I got so many people watching me
right now it's okay bye-bye
[Music]
you